a little more ACOs a lot you and I care
- how are you guys doing
the truth is handling that we've been
able to raise for the Syrian refugees
we've been able to raise 190 thousand
pounds just using our platforms my
platform on social media and lead ours
platform and will seem that bad platform
now that shows you the power of social
media but also shows you how much we can
do in Ramadan and how much we have been
able to help
shall I you can just imagine that money
being used now to to feed the most
vulnerable individuals how much how many
lives you probably have saved actually
yeah and it's a lot of Francis woman I
hear advocate and them are here and
Nessa Jimmy oz whoever saves a life as
if you said the all of you might all of
humanity right a very famous person over
on chapter five verse number 32 so
subhanAllah we've been able to do that
and we've approached near the end of
Ramadan we're in the last 10 nights of
ramadan this is just a quick message to
just kind of push because we need to get
to at least 200 so we can say we've done
200 guys let's push and Charlie this is
a great cause and we're always regularly
going down we know these guys are on the
ground these guys even go to Iraq on the
ground these guys go everyone on the
ground and I've been with them to many
different other places I've been to you
know I've been to Cox's Bazaar with them
on the bird on the Burma border I've
been to Ghana with them and the Chuckle
are going to be going to more places
with them because we're seeing with our
very own eyes you know they're
transformative material effects of this
of this contribution that you're putting
forward and inshallah nor only does it
have an effect by the way I just want to
make this point clear normally doesn't
have an effect on the immediate
situation in terms of food and hunger
and allowing for obviously them to
satiate themselves in the short term but
also it has a multiplier effect from an
economic perspective because these your
contribution or our contribution acts
like a proper lifeline for them which
allows not only them to be able to feed
and clothe themselves but it allows
these individuals to be able to you know
go get jobs actually frankly you know go
make it live and be able to properly
make a living for themselves build
themselves up as human beings and that's
what this area of the world needs and
this one
people who particularly have been
displaced and I've had the worst kind of
time so let's push as much as we can
because the Prophet Muhammad SAW time
told us that the best of people of those
who aren't most and found the most
useful to other people you know and it's
better I listen to this a lot of people
might be doing a decaf in the message it
now but it's better for you to be at
your brother's side in a time of need
then - this is a hadith who's been
authenticated by many of them my hadith
in then to do a tea carefully measured
for a whole month
you know Allah so let's let's keep
pushing let's be as useful to people as
possible and let's get the rewards of
giving charity which of course in our
religion is one of the biggest things
you can do said I wanna come ye but
again